This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客节目。百分之二。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例只有百分之二。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，我将为您剖析坚韧不拔的精神、体能训练以及如何培养适应力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你终将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》，名字就是数字 2。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个声名狼藉的诈骗犯时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我一定做他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他罪有应得。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话，相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回首往事》(The Look Back at It) 播客。从 1979 年开始，那对我和很多人来说都是个大日子。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you're not. that you need to.
请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回首往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》(Learn the Hard Way)。这个空间专注于黑人的心路历程，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在别处可能并不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着一套坚硬的盔甲。这向全世界暗示你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你没有这种能力，就代表你不需要卸下防备。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy
请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《知难而进》。2023年，《单身汉》(Bachelor) 明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父，但这场怀孕
appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian.
似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个遭遇过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners,
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱的陷阱》(Love Trapped)。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱的陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》(The Psychology of Your 20s)，在这里，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，
wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, my lovely listeners, we're talking about something a little bit different, a little bit less positive, a little bit less uplifting than I'm sure you guys are used to. In fact, like the complete opposite of all of that, we are talking about hate and why we secretly love to hate, why we secretly love being haters. Be honest with me here. There is something in all of us, whether you are in touch with it or not, that may be slightly envious of other's success, even if you try not to be, that maybe enjoys the drama of reality TV, even if you know, like, oh, maybe this isn't the best, that secretly kind of gets hooked by
无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们一直在剖析二十岁的心理学。今天，我可爱的听友们，我们要谈论一个有点不同的话题，它可能没有那么积极，也没有那么鼓舞人心，不像你们平时习惯的那样。事实上，简直与这一切完全相反，我们要谈的是“恨”，以及为什么我们暗地里喜欢去恨，为什么我们暗地里喜欢当一个“黑粉”（喷子）。在这里对我说实话。我们每个人内心深处，无论你是否意识到这一点，可能都对别人的成功带有一丝嫉妒，哪怕你尽量克制；或者哪怕你知道“噢，这或许不是最好的”，你可能还是会享受真人秀里的抓马；亦或是你暗地里会被公众的愤怒或取消文化所吸引，从而享受当一个“黑粉”的乐趣。说实话，你知道的，有时我也会过分沉迷于名人抓马。这就像是我的一个小爱好，尽管我知道我不该这样，尽管我知道其中90%的信息都是不准确的。特别是当我深知遭受公众攻击、面对私信里成群结队的愤怒网民说出恶毒言语是多么艰难的时候。但这就和我们被八卦吸引，或者想知道情侣们都在为什么争吵是出于同一个原因。我们迷恋那种高度刺激的感觉，以及针对他人宣泄恶意时的社交元素。就像我说的，我可以相当笃定地认为，在座的每位
public outrage or by cancel culture that enjoys being a hater. I'll be honest, you know, sometimes I get way too into celebrity drama. It's like my guilty pleasure when I know I shouldn't, when I know that, you know, 90% of it is incorrect. And especially when I know how hard it is to receive public hate and have a lot of angry people in your DM saying awful things. But it's like the same reason that we get drawn to gossip or wanting to know what couples argue about. We love the heightened sensations and the social element to hating on other people. Like I said, I would make a pretty good guess that everyone
听众在生命中的某个时刻都感受过这种奇怪的情绪。无论你是否愿意承认，这里没有羞耻感。我们只是来这里公开讨论人类的经历。而且我认为，就像任何情绪一样，“恨”，特别是我们现在谈论的这种“恨”，其实要温和一点。它有一个故事。这并不一定意味着你是个坏人，但我们参与这种渴望去讨厌别人或当“黑粉”的程度，正是这一点，让它从一个单纯的想法——一个我们最终其实能够控制的想法，变成了一种完全不同的东西。所以这就是我们要探讨的。所以这就是我们今天要谈论的。我们要探究这种“暗地里的恨”究竟从何而来，
listening has felt this weird emotion at some point in their lives. Whether you want to acknowledge it or not, there is no shame here. We're just here to talk openly about the human experience. And I think like every emotion hate, specifically the kind of hate we're talking about now, which is a little bit more benign. It has a story. It doesn't necessarily mean you're a bad person, but the extent to which we engage in our desire to hate other people or hate on other people, that is what takes it from just a thought, a thought that we ultimately have control over to something else entirely. And so that is what we are going to. And so that is what we are going to to talk about today. We're going to look at where this like secret hatred kind of comes from,
为什么从生物学角度来说，它感觉如此美妙，哪怕我们并不希望如此。随之而来的罪恶感宿醉，八卦心理学，取消文化心理学，为什么我们最亲密的朋友有时反而是我们最大的“黑粉”，以及更多内容。这可能是一场让人略感不舒服的对话，但我同时也觉得心理学是如此迷人且震撼人心。所以，废话不多说，让我们来聊聊为什么我们暗地里喜欢当个“黑粉”。请继续收听。那么，首先来回答一个非常简单的问题：是什么驱使我们对别人产生一点点敌意或厌恶？
why it like biologically feels so good even if we don't want it to. The guilt hangover that comes afterwards, the psychology of gossip, the psychology of cancel culture, why our closest friends are sometimes our biggest haters and so much more. I might be a little bit of an uncomfortable conversation, but I also think that psychology is so fascinating and like mind-blowing to me. So without further ado, let's talk about why we secretly love to be a hater. Stay with us. So to begin by answering a very simple question, what drives us to kind of hate on other people a little bit?
为什么这种感觉再次让我们觉得，有时坐下来进行一番荒谬的八卦痴迷、带着厌恶的心态去追真人秀，或者看到一个你非常讨厌的公众人物出丑，会让人感到如此满足？为什么这会让我们感到（你知道的）几乎很爽？我们需要知道的第一件事是，尽管这听起来可能很有争议，但这是一个事实：世界上没有所谓的坏情绪。只有会让我们感觉糟糕的负面情绪，或者可能会影响我们去做坏事的情绪。但那种认为某种情绪是纯粹邪恶、不纯洁且必须不惜一切代价去避免的想法是错误的。我们之所以认为愤怒、嫉妒、恨等情绪是坏的，很大程度上是因为受到了宗教的影响，以及我们在社会中如何被
Why does it again sometimes feel so fulfilling to sit down and have like a ridiculous gossip obsession to hate watch reality TV or maybe like see a public figure that you really don't like flounder. Why does that make us feel, you know, almost good? The first thing we need to know, and although this may sound controversial, it is a fact, there is no such thing as a bad emotion. There are negative emotions that can leave us feeling bad or there are emotions that can maybe influence us to do bad things. But the idea that an emotion is, holy evil, impure, and to be avoided at all costs is false. A lot of the reason why we see emotions like anger, envy, hate as bad is because of the influence of religion and how we have also
社交规训、排斥和羞辱那些特定的感受——这些感受最终确实可能会让人不舒服，可能会导致不好的行为，但它们仍然服务于某种奇怪的生物学和心理学目的。讨厌某些事物，甚至讨厌其他人，也没有什么不同。现在，在这里做一个快速澄清。我们不是在谈论演变成歧视或偏见的恨。我们不是在谈论仇恨犯罪并试图为之辩护。不，恨的感觉与我们为此采取的行动是两码事。但更重要的是，我们所谈论的那种恨是一种强烈的厌恶，它在某种程度上
been socially conditioned, shunned and shamed for certain feelings that ultimately, yes, may be uncomfortable, may lead to bad actions, but still serve a weird biological, psychological, purpose and disliking things, maybe even disliking other people is no different. Now, quick clarification here. We are not talking about hate that turns into discrimination or hate that turns into prejudice. We are not talking about hate crimes and trying to justify those. No, the feeling of hate and the actions we take in response to them are separate. But more importantly, the kind of hate we're talking about is an intense dislike that kind of serves
提供了一种信息，关于我们的价值观、我们的不安全感、我们的恐惧、我们的误解的信息，而我们有权选择去参与、去忽视或去克服它。这种选择非常重要。关于仇恨，有一点是肯定的：可能比任何其他情绪都更甚，我们从小就被告知要压抑它，它被妖魔化了，不管对错，但这实际上可能正是为什么当我们最终真正体验到它时，会觉得如此美妙的原因。
of information, information on our values, on our insecurities, our fears, our misunderstandings that we have a choice to either engage in, dismiss, or work through. And that choice is really important. The thing about hatred is that probably more than any other emotion, we have been told to suppress it and it has been demonized, whether rightly or wrongly, but that may actually be what causes it to feel so good when we finally do get to experience it. kind of more in like a pop culture or like social context. This is the catharsis theory of hate. The very fact that we are told not to feel it
这有点像流行文化或社交语境中的“宣泄理论”。我们被告知不准去感受它，这一事实本身
makes it so that when we indulge, when we hate on a celebrity, when we see someone fail, it's like this pressure is released. We finally do the forbidden thing and that mix of naughtiness, the buildup, the inherent social part of this as well is what brings a lot of people's satisfaction with being a hater.
使得当我们放纵自己去恨一个名人、当我们看到某人失败时，就像体内的压力得到了释放。我们终于做了一件被禁忌的事，这种淘气的混合感、蓄积的情绪、以及其中固有的人际社交部分，正是给许多人带来当“黑粉”的满足感的原因。
There's been so much research over the years about why hate feels good. Another theory is that it's because it's so intense that it feels this way. It's just the intensity and the strength of the emotion that makes it almost pleasurable. It's that intensity that causes our brain to be flooded with neurotransmitters that we usually associate with happy positive emotions. Things like dopamine, serotonin, adrenaline, few other emotional states cause people to act as irrational. boldly, sometimes as terribly as hate does. Few emotions feel as powerful and strong and therefore sometimes as good. Some very interesting research actually from only a couple of years ago, 2023, actually found as well that hate is one of the only so-called negative emotions that can
多年来有大量研究探讨为什么“恨”会让人感觉良好。另一个理论是，因为这种情绪太强烈了，所以才会有这种感觉。正是这种情绪的强度和力度，让它几乎变得令人愉悦。正是这种强度导致我们的大脑被神经递质淹没，而这些神经递质通常与快乐、积极的情绪相关。比如多巴胺、血清素、肾上腺素。很少有其他情绪状态能让人表现得像恨那样不理智、大胆，有时甚至是如此糟糕。很少有情绪能让人感觉如此强大有力，因此有时也感觉如此美妙。事实上，一些来自几年前（2023年）的非常有趣的研究也发现，恨是唯一一种能够
actually coexist with happiness. So it's possible to be hateful and to hate on other people and to also still be happy at the same time, whereas when we feel other negative emotions like envy, like anxiety, like grief, often that means the absence of happiness. So it's interesting that like hate kind of sits in this weird in between. Is it a negative emotion? Is it a positive emotion? Because it makes us feel good, but socially we've been conditioned and we know that it doesn't always lead to good outcomes. That's what makes it so confusing. So yes, it is not just you. Hate has this weirdly enjoyable tinge to it and what is one of the primary ways we express our dislike or hate for someone else gossip gossip what some people call the oldest human language let's talk about it for a second
与快乐共存的所谓负面情绪。所以，怀有恨意、讨厌别人，同时依然感到快乐是有可能的；而当我们感受到其他负面情绪时，比如嫉妒、焦虑、悲伤，通常这意味着快乐的缺失。所以有趣的是，恨似乎处于这种奇怪的中间地带。它究竟是负面情绪？还是正面情绪？因为它让我们感觉良好，但在社交上我们被规训过，我们也知道它并不总能带来好的结果。这就是让它如此令人困惑的地方。所以，是的，这不只是你个人的感觉。恨确实带有一种奇怪的、令人愉悦的色彩，而我们表达对他人厌恶或恨意的最主要方式之一是什么呢？八卦。八卦，被某些人称为人类最古老的语言，我们来谈谈这个。
every single one of us gossips let's just put it out there um i don't know anyone who doesn't they might not label it as gossip but it still is even if we know we shouldn't even if we have been the victim of it even if we try our hardest not to like it or not to indulge in it. Gossip is essentially a pretty ancient survival mechanism. It is what has allowed us to navigate social contexts for as long as humans have been able to communicate. Let's do a little bit of a very ancient history lesson. In a tribe of 150 people or even more, you know, our ancestors couldn't know everyone personally. And yet they needed to know who was trustworthy who was a potential threat and who should be avoided. Gossip, therefore, serves as
我们每个人都会八卦，我们就开门见山地说吧，嗯，我不认识不八卦的人。他们可能不会给它贴上“八卦”的标签，但它依然是，即便我们知道不该这么做，即便我们曾是它的受害者，即便我们竭尽全力不去喜欢它或不去沉溺其中。八卦本质上是一种相当古老的生存机制。只要人类能够交流，它就是让我们得以在社交环境中游刃有余的工具。让我们来上一堂非常古老生动的历史课。在一个拥有150人甚至更多的部落里，我们的祖先不可能认识每一个人。然而，他们需要知道谁是值得信任的，谁是潜在威胁，谁应该被避开。因此，八卦充当了
kind of a form of social intelligence, a way to basically learn about the reputation and behaviours of others in the group without direct potentially risky interactions and without having to watch them constantly to really know what kind of person they are. In this way, you know, some people do call Gossip a deeply pro-social act. It helps to enforce social norms, builds a sense of community and trust within an in-group by sharing this private information. It also allows us to police or monitor other people's behavior, a group's behavior, without resorting to violence or confrontation. It's a very fundamental part of human social bonding.
一种社会智能的形式，一种无需进行直接且可能存在风险的互动、也无需时刻盯着他们以真正了解他们是什么样的人，就能了解群组中其他人的声誉和行为的方式。通过这种方式，有些人确实将八卦称为一种深度的亲社会行为。它有助于强化社会规范，通过分享这些私人信息在内群体中建立社区感和信任感。它还允许我们监督或监控其他人的行为、一个群体的行为，而无需诉诸暴力或对抗。这是人类社会凝聚力中非常基础的一部分。
If you're thinking, yeah, I'm not buying it. There's literally no way gossip has ever been helpful. I totally get where you're coming from. I think we have all been at the sharp end of someone else's. hateful thoughts or opinions about us expressed through gossip. But a way that me and my friends have used gossip is actually to stay safe when dating. So one of our friends went on this date with this guy a couple of months ago and had a pretty terrible, kind of scary experience with this guy.
如果你在想：“是的，我才不买账。八卦绝对不可能是帮倒忙的。”我完全理解你的想法。我想我们都曾体验过别人通过八卦表达对我们的充满恨意的想法或意见所带来的尖锐伤害。但我和我的朋友们使用八卦的一个方式，实际上是在约会时为了保持安全。所以，几个月前，我们的一个朋友跟一个男生约会，结果和这个男生有了一次非常糟糕、甚至有点吓人的经历。
Anyways, a few months later, we're at a party. She got to speaking to a girl at this party. And this girl was like, had just mentioned that she just met the same guy. and as kind of interested in this guy and they're kind of dating. You can guess how that conversation went down. You know, my friend told the girl what happened to make sure she was cautious. She didn't say like, don't date this person. She was basically just like, hey, this is just information.
无论如何，几个月后，我们在一个派对上。她在这个派对上和一个女孩聊了起来。这个女孩刚好提到她刚刚认识了同一个男生，
You need to know, you can do with it what you wish. And the other girl was super appreciative. In this way, that is gossip. And that gossiping could have prevented her from going through the same awful experience that my friend had. This leads to a really crucial nuance. sometimes gossip isn't about being malicious at all. It's actually about a need for emotional processing and validation when direct confrontation isn't an option.
并且对这个男生有点兴趣，两人正在约会。你可以猜到那场对话是怎么进行的。你知道的，我的朋友把发生的事情告诉了那个女孩，以确保她保持警惕。她并没有说“别跟这个人约会”，她基本上只是说：“嘿，这些只是信息，你知道了之后可以自己做决定。”而另一个女孩非常感激。通过这种方式，这就是八卦。而那种八卦可能曾阻止了她经历和我朋友一样糟糕的体验。这就引出了一种非常关键的细微差别。有时八卦根本不是出于恶意。当直接对抗并非一种选择时，它实际上是为了满足情感处理和认可的需求。
Think about a time when, you know, you were so hurt or frustrated by someone, but you additionally felt like it was inappropriate to actually like express it to them. Maybe it was your boss. Maybe it was like a subtle betrayal from a friend and you can't confront them because you're in this big friendship group. It's going to make things awkward. the dislike that is bubbling in these circumstances, well, gossip may be a way of externalising what we have already said is a very intense emotion. It's like a form of venting of saying,
想象一下这样一个时刻：你被某人深深地伤害或感到沮丧，但你同时觉得向他们直接表达这些是不恰当的。也许那是你的老板。也许那是来自朋友的某种隐蔽的背叛，而你不能去和他们对质，因为你们身处一个大的朋友圈里。这会让事情变得尴尬。在这种情况下暗地里翻滚的厌恶感，好吧，八卦可能是一种将我们已经说过的非常强烈的情绪外化的方式。这就像是一种宣泄，在说：
this happened and it hurt, and I'm feeling a real wave of negativity. Am I crazy to be upset about this? Your social circle then kind of acts as a jury that validates your feelings, validates your perspective, but also gives you this outlet for a very uncomfortable emotion that isn't going to completely destroy the relationship in question. This is why, you know, some researchers have claimed gossip may be a form of emotional regulation for our hatred. Just like hate feels good and gossip feels good, there's also this other element of seeing someone else fail and that feeling good. It's so, even saying that and acknowledging that that is a feeling that we have
“这件事发生了，它伤害了我，我正感受着一波真正的负面情绪。因为这个而难过，我是疯了吗？”你的社交圈随后就会充当陪审团，认可你的感受，认可你的视角，同时也为你提供一个宣泄这种极度不舒服情绪的出口，而又不会彻底摧毁相关的这段关系。这就是为什么一些研究人员宣称，八卦可能是我们对恨的一种情绪调节形式。就像恨感觉很好，八卦感觉很好一样，还有另一个元素，那就是看到别人失败，那种感觉也很好。这种感觉，甚至连说出来并承认这确实是我们的一种感受，
makes me feel like, oh, probably shouldn't be talking about it. That's very, it's a secret human thing, but it's true. It's true. Sometimes it makes us feel good. This very powerful feeling has a name. It's referred to as a Schneidenfreude in German. And it's basically a word that refers to the way in which we take pleasure from hearing about someone else's misfortune.
都让我觉得：“哦，可能不应该谈论这个。”这非常隐秘，是人类的一种秘密心理，但这是真的。这是真的。有时它确实让我们感觉很好。这种非常强烈的感觉有一个名字。德语里称之为 Schadenfreude（幸灾乐祸）。它基本上是一个词，指代我们从听到别人的不幸中获得快乐的方式。
and it's a real thing. Brain imaging studies have shown that when we experience Schaden Freud, I hope I'm pronouncing it right, when we experience Shaden Freud, there we go, I butcher it, Shaden Freud, the brain's reward system, specifically this area called the ventral striatum, which we talk about a lot on the podcast, it lights up. It gives us a rush of feel-good neurochemicals, a whole big cocktail of them. this is actually the same part of our brain that activates when you eat chocolate, when you fall in love, when you experience any other different types of pleasure.
而这是真实存在的。脑成像研究表明，当我们体验到“幸灾乐祸”（Schadenfreude，希望我发音准确）时，当我们体验到这个词时——好吧，我把它读砸了，“幸灾乐祸”（Schadenfreude），大脑的奖励系统，具体来说是一个叫做腹侧纹状体的区域（我们在播客中经常谈到它），会被点亮。它会给我们带来一阵让人感觉良好的神经化学物质冲击，一大杯混合剂。
This reward is also tied to feelings of superiority. When someone we resent or feel as better than us fails, when they do something wrong or we interpret them to be doing something irritating or bad, it reaffirms our own sense of self-worth even for a brief moment. And that therefore restores a sense of justice or balance in our minds, especially if that person is someone who has previously harmed us or who has previously laughed at our missteps. It's an ego defense mechanism that makes us feel good about ourselves at another's expense. In a world of, you know, constant social comparison, that little burst of dopamine can be powerful. it can be a motivator, even if we don't want to admit that this is how we feel about it.
这种奖励实际上也与优越感息息相关。当我们怨恨的人或我们觉得比我们优秀的人失败时，当他们做错了什么，或者我们认为他们在做一些烦人的或糟糕的事情时，它会重申我们自身的自我价值感，哪怕只是短暂的一瞬间。因此，这在我们心中恢复了一种正义感或平衡感，尤其是如果这个人曾经伤害过我们，或者曾经嘲笑过我们的失误的话。这是一种自我防御机制，让我们以牺牲他人为代价来感觉自己良好。在这个充满持续社会比较的世界里，那种小剂量的多巴胺可能会非常强大。它可能成为一种动力，即使我们不想承认这就是我们对它的感受。
But of course, that's not the whole story. I think the flip side of feeling hateful towards someone, cheering on their failures, gossiping about someone, is that, well, firstly, we know it's not a nice way to feel about other people. It can create a pretty, like, I don't even know the word, like, sludgy, disgusting feeling in our brain that we shouldn't be feeling this way. Secondly, it's bad for our reputation. Thirdly, it can ostracize an individual when maybe they don't deserve to be ostracized. Thirdly, up to third or fourth, it can become a snowball where people start really piling on someone who maybe just made a small mistake and doesn't deserve everyone's suppressed anger to be like thrown directly at them.
但当然，这并不是全部。我认为，对某人心怀恨意、为他们的失败叫好、八卦某人的另一面是，首先，我们知道这不是对别人的好感觉。它会在我们的大脑中产生一种非常……我甚至不知道该用什么词，就像是一团黏糊糊、令人作呕的感觉，让我们觉得自己不应该有这种感觉。其次，这对我们的声誉有害。第三，它可能会孤立一个人，而这个人可能并不罪不至此。第三，或者说到第四，它可能会变成滚雪球效应，人们开始真正地群起攻击一个可能只是犯了个小错误、并不值得所有人倾泻压抑怒火的人。
And finally, you know, research shows that engaging in this kind of malicious feeling or malicious gossip or malicious behavior can actually harm your own well-being. And it leads to a lot of intense feelings of guilt and shame. That's our empathy kicking in. That's the rational, thoughtful part of our brain that is often silenced by the emotional intensity of hatred switching back on. because we all eventually realized like, hey, if this was me, I would feel devastated to know what those people were saying. I would feel terrible. I would feel awful.
最后，研究表明，参与这种恶意的感觉、恶意的八卦或恶意的行为，实际上会损害你自己的幸福感。这会导致大量强烈的罪恶感和羞耻感。那是我们的同理心在发挥作用。那是我们大脑中理性、深思熟虑的部分，它常常被重新开启的仇恨的情绪强度所压制。因为我们最终都意识到：“嘿，如果这是我，知道那些人在说这些话，我会感到崩溃的。我会觉得糟糕透顶。我会觉得太可怕了。”这是一种暂时的亢奋。恨是一种暂时的亢奋，但它对多个人来说都伴随着真实的情感代价。这也是一颗难以下咽的苦药，但仇恨带来的心理和生理成本，主要由恨人者承担，而不是被恨的人。你知道的，一时的恨意或八卦，可能会让人觉得有回报。但从长远来看，结果是你最终背负着长期的愤怒、怨恨，你最终会通过“这个人身上有什么我可以批评的”这种滤镜来看待别人。
I would be distraught at being thought of in that way. It's a temporary high. Hate is a temporary high that comes with a real emotional cost for multiple people. It's also a bitter pill to swallow, but the psychological and physiological cost of hate is primarily held by the hater, not the hated. You know, a moment of hate or gossip, it can feel rewarding. The long-term reality of it, though, is that you end up carrying chronic anger, resentment, you end up seeing people through a lens of what about them can I criticize.
“他们身上有什么缺点能让我对自己感觉更好？”你知道的，我们都听过那句名言：抱着愤怒或恨意不放，就像自己喝下毒药却期待别人去死。那个观点是真的。背负怨恨在身体上会伤害我们。这是有科学依据的。当我们愤怒时，当我们充满恨意时，我们的身体会激活压力应对系统。当你长时间背负着这种苦涩时，你的身体就会陷入一种低级别的紧急状态，因为我们知道仇恨的情绪强度总是会在我们内心引发一种深刻的感受。因此，如果这种深刻的感受一直被允许释放，它也会不断导致我们
What about their failings will make me feel better about myself? You know, we've all heard of that phrase, holding onto anger or hatred as like drinking poison and expecting the other person to die. that idea is true. Carrying resentment harms us physically. It's backed by science when we are angry, when we are hateful, our body activates its stress response system. When you carry that bitterness for a long time, your body is stuck in a state of low level emergency because we know the emotional intensity of hatred will always elicit a deep feeling in us. And so if that deep feeling is constantly being, you know, allowed through, it's constantly also causing us
分泌皮质醇等压力荷尔蒙。它会不断导致我们的心率加快。它会不断在我们的身体中引发紧张感，随着时间的推移，这真的会对我们的健康产生毒害。上世纪80年代一篇非常著名的论文发现，慢性敌意、慢性恨意与高血压、免疫系统减弱以及体内炎症迹象增加有关，而这些都是众所周知的导致心脏病和许多其他疾病的诱因。这就是你为恨付出的无声代价。我认为这种毒性和敌意也会让我们陷入持续的胡思乱想中，
to pump out stress hormones like cortisol. It's constantly causing our heart rate to be faster. It's constantly calling for tension in our body, which over time does become really toxic for our health. One very famous paper from the 1980s, it was one of the first papers of its time to find that chronic hostility, chronic hatred is linked to high blood pressure, a weaker immune system, and an increase in signs of inflammation in the body, all of which are known contributors to heart disease and so many other illnesses. That is the silent price you pay for hate. I think this toxicity and hostility can also keep us in a constant state of rumination,
陷入一个非常负面的思维死循环，让我们无法停止寻找别人的缺点，我们无法停止沉迷于别人的垮台，我们无法停止在遇到新的人或与其他人交往时，立刻产生最糟糕的想法。那个负面思维的循环，是精神健康状况不佳的强大预测指标。以及焦虑和抑郁等心理健康困难。这就好像你脑子里怎么也甩不掉那首歌。你只是不停地想着这个人惹恼你的方式，或者他们那次真的惹火你的言论。我最近和一个朋友经历过这个，我的一个朋友告诉我，
a really negative thought loop where we cannot stop looking for bad things about other people, We cannot stop obsessing over other people's downfalls. We cannot stop immediately having the worst thought first when we meet someone new or when we are engaging with other people. That negative thought loop, that is a powerful predictor of poor mental health. And mental health difficulties like anxiety and depression. It's like you cannot get the song out of your head. You just keep thinking about the way this person annoys you or the thing they said that one time that really upset you. I've had this recently with a friend, like a friend of mine was telling me about how
我们都认识的一个人，我本来会把她当成朋友的，对这个播客有一些看法，对我的工作有一些看法，并且显然已经把那些刻薄的看法公开发表给我身边的人了。整个周末，我都无法停止思考这件事。我无法停止去想我有多生气。也许我的一部分正试图用那些想法去报复她。我对这个人感到如此充满恨意和残酷。然后我说：“我才是那个承担这一切的人。我现在才是那个因此受到最大伤害的人。”但我理解为什么会这样。这基本上只是你的大脑在试图理清这一切。这也让你无法找到平静，并会让你感到筋疲力尽，甚至更加
someone, we both know who I would have considered a friend, like had some opinions about this podcast, had some opinions about my work and has like obviously openly expressed those kind of mean opinions to people close to me. And all weekend, I just couldn't stop thinking about it. I couldn't stop thinking about how mad I was. Maybe a part of me was trying to get back at her with those thoughts. And I was feeling so hateful and, like, cruel towards this person. And I was like, I'm the one bearing this. I'm the one who was hurting from this the most right now. But I understand why it's happening. It's basically just your brain trying to make sense of it all. It also makes it impossible to try and find peace. And it can leave you feeling exhausted and even more
痛苦。你知道那句话吗，你的大脑或者你的思想会变成你思考最多的东西。基本上，你对某件事想得越多，它就越开始支配你所有的其他想法。这就是这里正在发生的事情。你拥有的充满恨意的想法越多，你就会有更多充满恨意的想法。就像，它只会不断地复合、复合、复合。有趣的是，2023年发表在《当前心理学》(Current Psychology) 杂志上的一项研究调查了112名以上的参与者样本。他们的基本发现是，尽管八卦和心怀恨意可能会瞬间提升自尊，但从长远来看，那些爱八卦、参与其中的人，实际上自我感觉更糟糕，他们的幸福感指标随着时间的推移而下降，
bitter. You know, the saying, like, your brain becomes or your thoughts become what you think about the most. Basically, the more you think about something, the more it begins to dominate over all other thoughts. And this is what's happening here. The more hateful thoughts you have, the more hateful thoughts you have. Like, it just compounds and compounds and compounds. Interestingly, a 2013 study published in the journal Current Psychology looked at a sample of over 112 participants. And what they basically found was that although gossiping and being hateful might instantly spike self-esteem over the long run, people who gossip, people who engage in this, actually they felt a lot worse and their well-being indicators decreased over time,
特别是在分享了关于他们认识的人的信息之后，特别是是在八卦并说了那些他们明知不该说的话之后。有时，我们觉得，“好吧，如果这个人对说了我的坏话，那他们肯定活该我说他们的坏话”，我们会觉得这是情有可原的，但证据表明并非如此。当然，我们永远不可能和所有人都合得来，有些人确实对我们做错了事，不再值得在我们的生命中占有一席之地。但如果你讨厌一个人只是因为“无缘无故”，或者如果你讨厌一个人，甚至从未见过他们，或者他们曾经做过伤害你的事但已经真诚道歉并表现出悔意，
specifically after sharing this information about someone they knew, specifically after gossiping and saying things they knew they shouldn't have. Sometimes, you know, we feel like, well, if this person said something bad about me, well then surely they deserve for me to say bad things about them and we feel justified but the evidence suggests otherwise now of course we're never going to get on with everybody some people also do genuinely do us wrong and don't deserve a place in our lives anymore but if you don't like someone just because or if you don't like someone and you've never even met them or they have done something to hurt you but genuinely apologised and showing remorse and
并且表现出悔意，也许是时候开始放下，开始释怀了，而不是去喝那杯毒药。如果不是为了别的，仅仅是为了保护你自己的内心平静。我们绝对需要一种更好的方式来对待愤怒，更好地对待恨以及想要当个“黑粉”的渴望。所以我们要稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我想快速讨论另一个非常重要的元素，那就是网络喷子和网络仇恨，然后给你们一些建议，一些指导，教你们如何正确地接纳我们所有人自然都会有的这种充满恨意的感觉。所以请继续收听。《2%》。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例只有百分之二。
shown remorse, it might be time to maybe start suffering and maybe start letting that go rather than drinking the poison. If for no other reason, then purely to protect your own peace. We definitely need a better approach to anger, a better approach to hate and the desire to be a little bit of a hater. So we're going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to just quickly discuss one other very important element of this, which is internet trolls and internet hate and then give you some kind of tips, some kind of guidance for how to properly integrate the hateful feelings that we all naturally have. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将为您剖析坚韧不拔的精神、体能训练以及在这个光怪陆离的现代社会中培养适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康与健身专家等人对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你终将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。名字是数字 2 的 Percentage，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了，
fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience
因为人们在用记分牌观看生活，生活变成了赢与输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得当一个好人很重要，当你活在世上的时候，还是说你当一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种截然不同的意图，兄弟，绝对是的，那是两个不同层级的信任。
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough
我希望你真正地成为一个好人。加入我和科尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《知难界进》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个遭遇过同样事情的男士。格雷格，阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·纳兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。
I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones.
这是《爱的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱的陷阱》播客。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Naranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是这么说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新一季的《闺蜜》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个声名狼藉的诈骗犯。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事？
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
警察似乎并不关心，所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓我将成为他最后一个目标。他罪有应得。请收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。
play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回首往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对谈，畅谈80年代的快克。需要澄清的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊当天的快克，但为了让大家知道我的意思。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回首往事》。好吧，我们在探讨为什么当黑粉感觉很好时，绝对不能不谈网络喷子以及他们如何将仇恨变成自己的传染性病毒。我曾和喷子有过交锋，人们听到总是感到非常惊讶，因为我觉得多亏了你们，我真的生活在互联网一个非常和平的角落。但我认为，一旦网络上的某些东西吸引了，比方说，我不知道，大约5,0000名观众，
And I'm Alex. English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
甚至可能更少，就会有一个临界点，总会有人不喜欢你发布的内容，或者不喜欢你，或者没有任何理由地不喜欢你在做的事，只是想当个黑粉攻击你。而且这总是同一类个人资料或同一类人。总是那种没有头像、没有名字、零发帖、零粉丝的个人资料。你一眼就能看出，你知道，这是某人的喷子账号。这是一个他们专门为了这个精确目的而创建的账号，目的是让别人感觉不好。你知道吗？我想，如果有人对我有意见，并且敢于大声说出来，用他们的大号直言不讳，那我也就罢了。我想我至少还能为这一点尊敬他们。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, we cannot talk about why it feels good to be a hater without talking about internet trolls and how they make hate their own contagious virus. I've had my run-ins with trolls, which people are always really surprised to hear because I feel like I really do inhabit a really peaceful corner of the internet, thanks to you guys. But I think as soon as something online reaches an audience of, let's say, I don't know, like 50,000 people,
但这种由于匿名性而进一步沉溺于当黑粉快感的人，内心深处有一种真正的懦弱。他们永远不必将自己置于聚光灯下。所以退一步说，我必须指出，网络喷子并不只是一个不同意你观点的人。我非常支持那种讨论。网络喷子是那种进入对话、某个人的评论区、播客节目或视频的人，
maybe even less, at that, there's like a level there is a threshold where there will always be someone who does not like what you have posted or who does not like you or who has no reason to not like what you're doing but just wants to hate on you. And it's always the same kind of profile or person. It's always a profile that has no face, no name, zero posts, zero followers. And you can just tell, you know, this is someone's troll account. This is an account they have deliberately made for this exact purpose to make others feel bad. You know what? I think I wouldn't mind if someone had an opinion about me and just set it with their chest and just set it with their main account and came out with it. I think I could at least respect them for that.
他们唯一的意图基本上就是惹恼这个人。他们评论的目的是为了得到某种回应或反应。所以他们通常会没完没了地继续下去，直到他们觉得“挖到金子”或者直到他们引发了众怒。
But there is like a real deep cowardice to these kinds of people who lean even further into the thrill of being a hater because of this anonymity. They never have to put themselves on the line. So to go back a step, I do have to say an internet troll is not just someone who disagrees with you. I'm super down for that. An internet troll is someone who enters a conversation or someone's comment section or a podcast episode or a video. basically with the only intention being to upset the individual. The aim of their comments is just to get some kind of response or reaction. So they'll often keep going and going until they like kick gold or until they hit the pipeline.
但这种利用匿名性进一步沉迷于当喷子的快感的人，骨子里其实有一种极深的懦弱。他们永远不需要承担任何风险。所以退一步讲，我必须说明，网络喷子可不仅仅是那些与你意见不合的人。我完全赞成健康的意见不合。网络喷子是指那些进入某个对话、某人的评论区、某期播客或某个视频的人，他们基本上只有一个目的，那就是惹恼当事人。他们评论的目的是为了得到某种回应或反应。所以他们往往会没完没了地纠缠下去，直到他们像是挖到金矿，或者戳中了痛点为止。
The comments get nastier, the slander gets even more personal or with the aim of offending and causing upset. It's something that brings them pleasure. Who are the people behind these comments and behind these. online attacks. Well, researchers only a couple of years ago identified that online trolls are not just angry people who are venting. They often possess a very specific cluster of personality traits that cause them to enjoy making other people upset. This is known as the dark tetrad or the dark quad of personality traits and it includes, firstly, narcissism. A lot of these online trolls have
评论变得愈发恶毒，诽谤也变得更加针对个人，其目的就是为了冒犯和激怒他人。这能给他们带来快感。这些评论和网络攻击的幕后黑手究竟是谁呢？研究人员在几年前就发现，网络喷子并不只是单纯在发泄怒气的愤怒之人。他们通常具有一组非常特殊的个性特征，这让他们乐于看到别人痛苦。这被称为人格特质的“黑暗四分体”，其中包括：首先，自恋。许多网络喷子都有着
inflated sense of self-importance and a deep need for admiration, which manifests as a feeling of entitlement to dominate spaces online. It also may be that, yes, they have a huge sense of self-importance, but in their lives, they're really not doing much. And so this is a way for them to feel better about their lack of success or the success they feel entitled to. They also have what we call machiavellianism. This is a cynical disregard for morality and a very manipulative strategic approach to social interactions, often using other people as their own source of amusement. They find it fun. They find it like a game of cat and mouse. They like to play with people in that way. Psychopathy, a lack of empathy, reduced capacity for guilt or remorse, and also a tendency
膨胀的自大感，对赞美有着极度渴望，这表现为一种在网络空间中主导一切的特权感。这也可能是因为，虽然他们确实有着强烈的自大感，但在现实生活中，他们其实并没有什么作为。因此，这是他们用来抚平自己缺乏成就感，或者弥补他们自认为应得的成就的一种方式。他们还具备我们所说的“马基雅维利主义”。这是一种对道德的冷漠蔑视，以及在社交互动中采取高度操纵性的策略方法，常常把他人当作自己寻乐的工具。他们觉得这很有趣。他们觉得这就像一场猫捉老鼠的游戏。他们喜欢以此来耍弄别人。精神病态，即缺乏同理心，内疚或悔恨的能力降低，并且倾向于
towards impulsive and thrill-seeking behavior. That's another core personality trait of these individuals. And finally, what we call everyday sadism. This is, again, the pleasure derived from inflicting psychological or emotional pain on others. This one trait, more than any other, is most strongly associated with trolling behavior. So just a refresh on those four traits, narcissism, Machiavellianism, psychopathy, and everyday sadism. These are the traits most common in our internet trolls. A 2014 study published in the Journal of Personality and Individual Differences actually looked at 12,000 people and it looked into both their internet commenting behaviour as well as asking them to complete a number of personality tests to measure elements
冲动和寻求刺激的行为。这是这些人的另一个核心人格特征。最后，就是我们所说的“日常施虐倾向”。这也是指通过给他人带来心理或情感上的痛苦来获得快感。这一特征比其他任何特征都更能强烈地与网络喷子行为联系在一起。所以，让我们重温这四个特征：自恋、马基雅维利主义、精神病态和日常施虐倾向。这些是网民中最常见的特征。2014年发表在《人格与个体差异》杂志上的一项研究实际上调查了12,000人，既考察了他们的网络评论行为，又让他们完成了一系列旨在衡量这些要素的
of this dark tetrad or dark quad. Unsurprisingly, the researchers found that those who said that trolling was their favourite online activity also scored the highest in the dark tetrad personality traits. The other thing about this study is that the authors even go as far as to say that these trolls see the internet as almost like a playground for them. They actually enjoy this kind of behavior. It is playful. It is pleasurable to taunt other people and to hate on them with the intention of getting
黑暗四分体人格特征的测试。毫无疑问，研究人员发现，那些表示喷人是他们最喜欢的网络活动的人，在黑暗四分体人格特征上的得分也最高。关于这项研究的另一件事是，作者甚至指出，这些喷子把互联网几乎看作是他们的游乐场。他们其实很享受这种行为。这很有趣。嘲弄他人并出于引发反应的目的去仇恨他们，能带给他们快感。
a reaction. The online environment and online space is that a lot of us, us find ourselves in currently are actually the perfect breeding ground for this type of hate, thanks to two key psychological factors. There is a reason why, you know, you walk along on the street and like, people aren't coming up to you and being like, I think this about you, or I'm going to just insult you, but then when you go online, there are like thousands and thousands, maybe even millions of people operating this way. Firstly, it's because, yes, they might be narcissist, they might be, you know, sadists, they're also cowards and they also don't have the
归功于两个关键的心理因素，我们许多人目前身处的网络环境和网络空间，实际上成为了滋生这种仇恨的完美温床。这就是为什么，你知道的，当你走在街上时，人们不会走过来对你说“我对你有这种看法”或者“我要去羞辱你”；但当你上网时，却有成千上万，甚至数百万的人以这种方式行事。首先，这是因为，是的，他们可能是自恋狂，可能是施虐狂，但他们也是胆小鬼，他们
freaking guts to say it. But secondly, again, it is that anonymity. The shield of a username or an avatar allows people to act without fear of real world consequences and social retribution. You can say something awful to someone and you will never have to face them. You will likely never meet them. You will never have to see the consequence. You will never have to see their tears, their friends, their family trying to comfort them, that makes it a lot easier for people to do and not feel guilty about. There's also this theory that it's actually the fact or the lack of eye contact specifically that causes this. The absence of this real-time social feedback where you can see the other person's eyes, you have this window into their soul, you can see them suffer and you
根本没有那个狗胆当面说出来。但其次，同样是因为匿名性。用户名或头像的盾牌让人们在行事时无需担心现实世界的后果和社交报应。你可以对某人说一些可怕的话，而你永远不必面对他们。你很可能永远不会见到他们。你永远不必看到后果。你永远不必看到他们的眼泪，以及他们试图安慰他们的朋友和家人。这让人们做起来容易得多，而且不会感到内疚。还有一个理论认为，实际上正是眼神接触的缺乏或缺失具体导致了这一点。缺乏这种你可以看到对方眼睛的实时社交反馈，你就失去了窥探他们灵魂的窗口，你看不到他们受苦，而你
are meant to feel something in response. The fact that there isn't that in these online spaces makes what you're doing feel less real and makes it easier for you to do. These factors have all combined to create the perfect environment for the uninhibited act of expressed hate. There it is. It's like all this pent up emotion that we all have. The pleasure that we all, you know, somewhat derive from hating on other people or feeling better because of someone else's downfall, which, you know,
本该对此有所感触。在这些网络空间中缺乏这一点，使得你的所作所为感觉不那么真实，从而让你更容易去做。这些因素结合在一起，为无所顾忌地表达仇恨创造了完美的环境。事情就是这样。这就像是我们所有人内心压抑的情感。那种我们所有人对仇恨他人，或是因为别人的垮台而感到一丝痛快的情绪，你知道的，
we could typically manage in a safe and healthy and sustainable way and process accurately, you know, or you could just go online and just be a hater. Which one takes less work? Also, it's worth saying, you know, the nature of modern day social media algorithms are designed to amplify extreme more emotionally charged content. And that creates these echo chambers where we are exposed to more hate and less nuance. maybe you have noticed this. I definitely have,
我们通常可以以一种安全、健康、可持续的方式来管理它并准确处理，或者，你也可以直接上网去当一个键盘侠。哪一种更省事呢？此外，值得一提的是，现代社交媒体算法的本质就是被设计来放大极端、更具情绪化的内容。这创造了回音室效应，让我们接触到更多的仇恨和更少的细微差别。也许你已经注意到了这一点。我绝对注意到了，
especially on Instagram, where there could be hundreds of positive comments on a reel or on a video or on an image. You go to the comment section, though, what's always at the top? If there is a hate comment, if there is a mean comment, it's always at the very top of that comment section.
特别是在Instagram上，一条短视频、视频或图片下面可能会有数百条正面评论。然而，当你查看评论区时，总是排在最上面的是什么？如果有仇恨评论，如果有恶毒评论，它总是位于评论区的最顶端。
Even if it has less likes, even if it has less engagement, the algorithm prioritizes this kind of, kind of intensity and vitrole and this emotional reaction that it knows it's going to pull people in. This constant exposure normalizes this being a normal response to other people. Because we always see it, because it's always there, because it's always the top comment, it normalizes that this is just like an everyday reaction that you are allowed to have about someone else's behavior. And it is not.
即使它的点赞数更少，互动量更低，算法也会优先考虑这种强度、尖酸刻薄以及它明知能够吸引人眼球的情绪反应。这种持续的接触将这种对他人行为的正常反应进行了常规化。因为我们总是看到它，因为它一直都在，因为它总是置顶评论，这就将它常规化了，让人觉得这只是你可以对别人的行为作出的日常反应。然而并不是。
So trolling is one element, but you might be thinking, listen, I have a private account, I'm not in the public eye, I don't really need to think about trolls. That is totally true. You might not have to worry about strangers on the internet, but something that a lot of people talk about is the fact that their biggest critics are sometimes the people that they are actually closest to in their lives. So why are some of our biggest haters, maybe not the people online, but our close? as friends, our family members even, our partners in some extreme cases. The core reason for this is rooted in a fundamental psychological principle, social comparison. Sure, we can compare ourselves to strangers on the other side of the world. It's pretty easy to do so, but what is an even easier and closer source of comparison, those in our immediate social circle, our best friend, our friendship group, our peers, our siblings.
所以，喷子只是一种元素，但你可能会想，听着，我有一个私人账号，我不是公众人物，我真的不需要考虑网络喷子。这完全正确。你可能不需要担心互联网上的陌生人，但许多人都在讨论的一个事实是，他们最大的批评者有时正是他们生活中最亲近的人。那么，为什么我们最大的黑粉有时不是网上的人，而是我们的至亲？是我们的朋友，甚至是我们的家庭成员，在某些极端情况下甚至是我们的伴侣。这背后的核心原因植根于一个基本的心理学原理——社会比较。当然，我们可以将自己与地球另一端的陌生人进行比较。这做起来挺容易的，但有一个更简单、更近的比较来源，那就是我们直接社交圈里的人，我们最好的朋友、朋友圈、同龄人、兄弟姐妹。
These are the people whose lives are most relevant to our own sense of self-worth. When you achieve some kind of personal success, maybe it's a promotion or you just got engaged or a huge personal milestone. And a friend or family member responds with like a subtle backhanded comment or jealousy or even outright hatred. It often takes us by surprise. We're like, wait, aren't you the one who's meant to be? the happiest for me, but often this is a reflection of their own deep-seated insecurity and envy.
这些人的生活与我们自身的自我价值感最息息相关。当你取得某种个人成功时，也许是一次升职，或者是你刚刚订婚，又或者达到了一个重大的个人里程碑，而某个朋友或家人却用含沙射影的言论、嫉妒甚至赤裸裸的仇恨来回应。这常常让我们感到措手不及。我们会想，等等，你不是应该最替我感到高兴的那个人吗？但通常这折射出的是他们自己内心深处的不安全感和嫉妒。
Your success has inadvertently highlighted something they feel they lack. They interpret your success and your achievements as they're down for, not realizing that obviously there is room for everyone. And the hate they direct at you is often a subconscious attempt to restore their own self-esteem by tearing yours down, which is bizarre. It's wild. I don't understand why it happens. I don't think it necessarily makes a lot of sense, but it is something that people talk about time and time again. The best friend who's just like always a little bit too gleeful when something goes wrong in your life, or the friend who is never really that happy for you when something goes well. those closest to us often have the deepest capacity for hate,
你的成功无意中凸显了他们觉得自己所缺乏的东西。他们把你的成功和成就解读为他们的失败，却没有意识到显然每个人都有发展的空间。他们针对你倾泻的仇恨，通常是潜意识里试图通过贬低你的自尊来恢复他们自己的自尊，这真是匪夷所思。太疯狂了。我不明白为什么会这样。我觉得这不一定合乎情理，但这确实是人们一次又一次谈论的现象。总有那么一个最好的朋友，在你生活出错时总是表现得有点太幸灾乐祸；或者每当你一切顺利时，那个朋友从不是真正地为你感到高兴。那些与我们最亲近的人，往往拥有最深沉的仇恨潜能，
not necessarily because their love was fake, but because love and hate draw from the same well of intimacy. It's particularly painful because it's coming from someone who does know you, who knows your vulnerabilities, who knows what you really are scared of, who knows your fears and their words, their backhand compliments, you know, that can hit with a precision. that a stranger, like a stranger online never could.
不一定是因为他们的爱是假的，而是因为爱与恨汲取自同一口亲密之井。这尤其痛苦，因为它来自一个确实了解你的人，一个了解你的脆弱、知道你真正害怕什么、知道你的恐惧的人。他们的话语和冷嘲热讽，能够以一种网上的陌生人永远无法企及的精准度直击要害。
And often we can be like, oh, you get a troll comment or someone like says something rude to you, like on the internet. You can be like, well, this person doesn't know me. They're not important in my life. The stakes are entirely different when it's someone who literally you would trust with your life, who you would trust with so much of yourself. A lot of these personal grievances, again, stem from insecurity and are. a deep act of projection. I feel like a lot of us have heard of the term projection before. It's a
通常我们可能会觉得，哦，你收到了喷子的评论，或者有人在网上对你说粗鲁的话。你可以想，这个人根本不了解我。他们在我的生活中并不重要。而当这个人是你 literally（字面意义上）会托付生命、会向其倾注极大自我的人时，情况就完全不同了。很多这类的个人恩怨，同样源于不安全感，并且是一种深层的投射行为。我觉得我们很多人以前都听过“投射”这个词。它是
rather amorphous psychological term that I think just gets like thrown around. But it basically means that someone holds a mirror up to us and what we see in that reflection, what we see in that mirror, we don't like. And so instead of realizing that we don't like it because it's something that we don't like about ourselves and that we are critical of ourselves about, we target the reflection of that in someone else. So basically it means that the things you hate the most about other people are the things that you see as being most true about your own character. There are so many studies, too many to count that reference this, but basically, again, when we don't feel good, sometimes it is easier to bring others down than it is to acknowledge that we don't really
一个相当形而上的心理学术语，我觉得它总是被到处滥用。但它基本上意味着，有人为我们举起一面镜子，而我们在镜中的倒影里、在那面镜子中所看到的，是我们所不喜欢的。因此，我们没有意识到我们不喜欢它是因为这是我们自身所不喜欢、并且自我批判的特质，而是将它在别人身上的倒影作为攻击目标。所以基本上这意味着，你最讨厌别人的地方，正是你认为在自己性格中最真实的部分。有太多的研究（多到数不过来）都提到了这一点，但基本上，同样地，当我们感觉不好时，贬低他人往往比承认我们此刻其实并不
like ourselves right now. A lot of hate, it does stem from our own state of psychological well-being. In fact, I think every single example that we have given in this episode is evidence of that. Is evidence of the fact that in order to gossip, in order to troll someone, in order to try and tear someone down, in order to cheer on someone's downfalls imminent, there has to be something about your own life that doesn't feel amazing at that point. you know, someone whose life is full of love, someone who has confidence in their life, someone who has, you know, something that they are invested in in their life, they don't have the time and the energy to be focused on what's going on beyond them or beyond their closest circle. They don't have time to be trolling the internet looking for someone to make themselves feel better by making someone else feel worse.
喜欢自己要来得容易。大量的仇恨确实源于我们自身的心理健康状况。事实上，我认为我们在本期节目中给出的每一个例子都是这方面的证据。这证明了为了八卦、为了网暴某人、为了试图贬低某人、为了幸灾乐祸地期待某人即将垮台，你自己的生活在那个时候一定有什么地方让你感觉很不爽。你知道的，一个生活充满爱的人，一个对生活充满自信的人，一个有自己为之投入的事物的人，是没有时间和精力去关注自己之外或是最亲近圈子之外的事情的。他们没有时间在互联网上当喷子，去寻找能通过让别人感觉更糟糕来让自己感觉更好的人。
So it is a real deep truth about our desire to hate. Hatred also is really rooted in boredom, idleness, and frustration by our own life circumstances. When we talk about confronting hate in ourselves and confronting this negative feeling or dealing with it from other people and trying to integrate that and understand why someone doesn't like us,
所以，这是关于我们对仇恨的渴望的一个极其深刻的真相。仇恨实际上也根源于我们自身生活环境带来的无聊、闲散和挫败感。当我们谈论直面我们内心的仇恨、直面这种负面情绪，或是应对来自他人的这种情绪，并试图将其整合、去理解为什么有人不喜欢我们时，
it's never really about the person receiving the hate. They are just a conduit for something much larger. They are just a proxy. And I think that is important to recognize and realize and remember whatever side of the equation you are on. It's not really about them, is it? So on that note, if hate is so damaging to us, if it stems from insecurity in such a deep,
这其实永远与接受仇恨的人无关。他们只是某种更大东西的渠道。他们只是一个替代品。我认为无论你处于方程式的哪一方，认识到、意识到并记住这一点都很重要。这其实与他们无关，对吧？既然如此，如果仇恨对我们的伤害如此之大，如果它以如此深沉、
sometimes ugly way, how do we break free from its cycle, both in ourselves and in our interactions with others? Well, we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through
有时甚至是丑陋的方式源于不安全感，我们该如何打破这个循环，无论是在我们自己身上还是在我们与他人的互动中？好吧，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将在这个奇怪的现代世界中，剖析心理坚韧、健身以及建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主宰健康行业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历
some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, health, your person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast,
一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Persent”。欢迎收听我的新播客，
Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kyr Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the
《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们
pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses steve burns dustin ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust i want you to just really be a good person join me keir gains is we have real conference conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
追求某种事物的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们靠记分牌来评判生活，生活变成了关于输赢的比赛，史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要，还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的，那是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。加入我的节目《Learn the Hard Way》，我们将探讨关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
《Learn the Hard Way》。打开您免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的诉讼战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子——格雷格·阿莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at America Copa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，来自亚利桑那州马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在I-Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never. mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
第二条规则，绝对不要去招惹她的朋友。我们总是这么说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he did. serves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会为自己的所作所为付出代价。请收听《闺蜜》。
Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击了小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
乔治·布什到底跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会带你来到这里，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
其中包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，但为了让大家知道……我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二期讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah, for me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. As much as I've tried to dive into the humanists and the universality of sometimes being a hater, how it sometimes does feel good, how a lot of us do it. Over time, it is not something to be celebrated and it does not make us feel good.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。尽管我曾试图深入探讨作为一个“黑粉”的人文主义和普遍性，探讨有时这样做感觉如何美好，探讨我们当中有多少人都在这样做。但随着时间的推移，这并不是一件值得庆祝的事，它也不会让我们感觉良好。
to be someone who only has bad things to say about other people. And we do have to call ourselves out on it for a number of reasons. Firstly, so that our brain doesn't become this like negativity machine. Secondly, so we are actually nice to be around. Thirdly, for just like the kindness and grace that we want to show other people that we would expect in their circumstances. We want to do onto others as we would want done onto ourselves. And addressing our relationship with the hate with.
成为一个只会对别人说坏话的人。出于种种原因，我们确实必须反思自己。首先，为了不让我们的大脑变成一个负能量机器。其次，为了让我们实际相处起来更讨人喜欢。第三，为了向他人展示我们希望在他们那种情况下也能得到的善良与宽容。我们希望别人怎样对待自己，就怎样对待别人。而正视我们与内心之中……
within us is a really important part of that and is a really important way that we're going to do that. So the first step is really, and I know I say this every single time, but it is self-awareness. The fact that you are listening to this episode and you may have nodded your head along to a couple of things and may have seen yourself in some of these descriptions, whether you want to acknowledge it or not, I actually think that's an amazing thing. And I think that you, like being able to see the ugliness in yourself is one of the most profound forms of self-awareness, even if it feels kind of uncomfortable. Someone who was truly a hateful, despicable person, someone who was truly a sadist or a psychopath or Machiavellian does not have the capacity to do that. So the fact
……恨意的关系是其中非常重要的一部分，也是我们将要做到这一点的至关重要的方式。所以第一步其实是——我知道我每次都这么说——那就是自我觉察。你正在收听这一集，你可能对其中的某些内容点头称是，并且在其中某些描述中看到了自己的影子，不管你是否愿意承认，我其实认为这是一件了不起的事。而且我认为，你能够看到自己丑陋的一面，是最高深的的自我觉察形式之一，尽管这感觉有点不舒服。一个真正充满恨意、卑鄙的人，一个真正的虐待狂、精神病患者或马基雅维利主义者，是没有能力做到这一点的。所以……
that you do shows that you're not like those people who find the routine of hate pleasurable. So now that you've acknowledged it, I think the next step is that when you feel the impulse to hate, to gossip, to lash out, just ask yourself. self. Pause. Like, what are you really feeling right now? What is the root of this feeling? Is it anger? Is it jealousy? Is it a lack of control? Is it powerlessness? Is it a fear of not being good enough? Remember, even if you are in the middle of saying something mean, right in the middle of writing a comment, right in the middle of hate watching something on TikTok or whatever, whatever you're doing, you can always just stop. Just because you have started an action doesn't mean that you are now fully committed to
……你做到了，这表明你并不像那些从仇恨的常规中寻找快感的人那样。所以，既然你已经意识到了这一点，我认为下一步就是，当你感受到想要去恨、去八卦、去抨击的冲动时，问问你自己。暂停。比如，你现在真正的感受是什么？这种感觉的根源是什么？是愤怒？是嫉妒？是缺乏控制感？是无力感？是对自己不够优秀的恐惧？记住，即使你正说到某个刻薄的话题，正准备写一条评论，正准备在TikTok上带着恨意围观某事，无论你在做什么，你随时都可以停下来。你开始了一项行动，并不意味着你现在就必须全心全意地……
finishing it. You can just stop. You can always just course correct and literally say to the other person or say to yourself like, actually, I'm sorry, I actually don't want to do this. I don't want to say that. I don't want to engage in this. I don't want to feel this way. I'm going to stop. I'm going to hit pause. I'm going to handle this differently. Sorry about that. A big root cause of our hate is often actually not pure dislike. It is often jealousy, insecurity and comparison. So in that way, acknowledging that also means that you can then begin to have a different relationship with envy and you can turn it into a compass rather than something that
……把它完成。你可以直接停下来。你随时都可以纠正方向，字面意义上对另一个人说或者对你自己说：其实，我很抱歉，我其实不想这样做。我不想说那些话。我不想参与其中。我不想这种感觉。我要停下来。我要按下暂停键。我要用不同的方式处理这件事。真是不好意思。我们恨意的很大一个根源，其实往往不是纯粹的厌恶。它通常是嫉妒、不安全感和比较。所以从这个意义上说，承认这一点也意味着你可以开始与嫉妒建立一种不同的关系，你可以把它变成一个指南针，而不是某种……
might allow you to hate on someone and give you that little spike of dopamine, but in the long term really actually harms you. When you feel that pang of envy or frustration at someone else's achievement or milestone, instead of letting it fester and instead of following the instinct to tear them down, literally say to yourself, okay, what about the situation do I actually want? If you are responding to their circumstances with such a level of intensity, that means that you must really be invested in what they're doing and you must really care about what they're doing and therefore a part of you probably wants it for yourself.
……可能会让你去恨别人并给你带来那种多巴胺小高潮，但从长远来看实际上会伤害你的东西。当你对别人的成就或里程碑感到一丝嫉妒或沮丧时，不要让它恶化，也不要顺从去贬低他们的本能，而是字面意义上对自己说：好吧，这个情况的哪一部分是我真正想要的？如果你对他们的情况做出如此强烈程度的反应，那就意味着你一定真的很投入他们在做的事，你一定真的很在乎他们在做的事，因此你内心的一部分可能也希望自己能拥有它。
so you can use the intensity of this feeling as information. A little mantra I like to say if I'm ever recognizing that feeling coming up is love that for them, want that for me. The first half of that mantra really recognizes, you know, the positivity in their experience, I love that for them. That looks great. I think that that, you know, European trip looks delightful. I think that their recent success is incredible and they really deserve that.
所以你可以把这种强烈感受当作信息。如果我发现这种感觉涌现，我喜欢说的一句小咒语是：为他们感到高兴，为自己争取想要的东西。这句咒语的前半部分确实承认了，你知道的，他们经历中的积极面，“我为他们感到高兴”。这看起来很棒。我认为那个，你知道的，欧洲之旅看起来令人愉快。我认为他们最近的成功是不可思议的，他们真的配得上这一切。
I want that for me. and pleads for them, and then that envy that I would normally feel is actually being redirected into a source of inspiration, into a tool for self-improvement, into motivation. Again, at the end of the day, if you didn't care, you wouldn't be hating on them. You literally cannot hate someone you don't care about. So engaging in this form of cognitive reappraisal, where you consciously change how you interpret a negative emotion and you make it productive, is really going to help you not just ruminate on what you're missing in your own life and not in some way blame them for what you're missing,
“我想要为自己争取这个。”并为他们祈祷，然后我通常会感受到的那份嫉妒，实际上就被重新定向为灵感来源、自我改进的工具、动力。话说回来，如果你不在乎，你就不会恨他们。你绝对不可能去恨一个你在乎的人。因此，进行这种认知重评，即你有意识地改变自己对负面情绪的解释并使其变得富有成效，真的会帮助你不再仅仅沉思于自己生活中缺少了什么，也不会以某种方式将你所缺少的东西归咎于他们……
but turn that into something you can do about it. I also think if you recognize that a lot of hatred and comparison is fueled by being on perhaps social media and the comparison that can fuel and how easy it is to like just jump on the bandwagon of everyone currently hating on someone, you've got to recognize like social media isn't real. You can also step away from it. and your life will not be over. I think we have this real dependency on social media now for all of our social needs and all
……而是将其转化为你可以付诸行动的事情。我也认为，如果你意识到许多恨意和比较是由身处社交媒体（以及它所助长的高度比较，以及盲目跟风去恨某人是多么容易）所驱动的，你就必须认识到，社交媒体并不是真实的。你也可以远离它，你的生活不会因此而结束。我认为我们现在对社交媒体有着真正的依赖，来满足我们所有的社交需求以及所有……
of our informational needs as well. Like, it's how we feel like we stay in the loop. It's how we feel like we connect with our friends. It's how we have those like incidental social interactions with people online. It's how we keep people in the loop. There are heaps of other ways to actually do all of those things without playing into an algorithm that is quite hateful. And even if that doesn't mean completely abstaining from social media, it might mean seeing something that immediately sparks your desire to hate and engaging
……的信息需求。比如，这就是我们觉得自己保持消息灵通的方式。这就是我们觉得自己与朋友保持联系的方式。这就是我们与网民进行这种偶然社交互动的方式。这就是我们让人们了解情况的方式。其实还有很多其他方法可以做到所有这些事情，而不必去迎合一个充满恨意的算法。即使这并不意味着完全戒掉社交媒体，它也可能意味着看到某样东西时，它立刻激起了你想恨的欲望，然后与之互动……
with it in a way that doesn't make it your problem. So unfollowing, blocking, muting people. I did a lot of that, I did a lot of that this week where I was just like, huh, this is really making me feel really terrible and it's really like playing into my desire and feeling my desire to like feel hateful and spiteful. And the thing is is that that emotion may be natural. It's also my responsibility and how I engage with that is my responsibility. Someone's allowed to have their opinion or express their thought or talk about whatever it is they want to talk about and it be none of my business. I'm allowed to disengage if it is possible for me. And if the possibility is there, I should take it.
……但不会让它成为你的问题。所以，取消关注、拉黑、将人静音。我做了很多这样的事，这周我做了很多，当时我就想：呃，这真的让我感觉太糟糕了，而且这真的在迎合我的欲望，助长了我想要产生恨意和恶意的渴望。问题在于，这种情绪可能是自然的。这也是我的责任，我如何处理它也是我的责任。允许某人拥有他们的观点、表达他们的想法或谈论他们想谈论的任何事情，这与我无关。如果可能的话，我有权退出。如果存在这种可能性，我就应该抓住它。
I will say I said this the other day to someone, to one of my friends, I was like, curation of your social media is actually a form of self-care. Like unfollowing and blocking people or just pressing not interested is a form of self-care. And we should do more of it. I think it's also really important to flip this around and learn how we can respond to hateful people. Unfortunately, it's something most of us will be on the receiving end of in some point in our lives, either in person or online. And there are some people who just like don't want to do anything about their hateful feelings. We're obviously sitting here and we're talking about ways to like psychologically manage how we act on hate.
我得说，我前几天对某个人、对我的一个朋友说过这样的话，我说：对社交媒体进行精选其实是一种自我关怀。比如取消关注和拉黑别人，或者直接点击“不感兴趣”就是一种自我关怀。我们应该多做一些。我认为同样非常重要的一点是，扭转这个局面，学习我们如何应对充满恨意的人。不幸的是，这是我们大多数人在生活中某个时刻都会面临的事情，无论是在现实中还是在网上。而且有些人就是不想对他们充满恨意的感觉做任何改变。我们显然坐在这里，在讨论如何在心理上管理我们对恨意的反应。
Some people literally just don't care. And it feels so good to them that they can keep riding the high with never experiencing maybe the psychological and emotional come down of this negativity. So how do you respond to a hater in a way that protects your own peace in a way that doesn't make you turn into them? It's important to remember that any time you're engaging with someone who wants to hate on you, whether it's a troll, whether it's a so-called friend, this is not about winning. This is not, like you will never win. You're never going to win against this kind of individual. It's about reclaiming your own emotional energy, protecting your own energy and setting a more firm boundary. you know, if hatred comes online, specifically with trolls, like, they do not care about winning.
有些人根本不在乎。这让他们感觉太好了，以至于他们可以一直保持这种兴奋状态，而永远不会体验到这种负面情绪带来的心理和情感上的低谷。那么，如何以一种保护你自己的平静、不让你变成他们那样的方式来回应一个“黑粉”呢？重要的一点是要记住，任何时候当你与一个想恨你的人互动时，无论是喷子，还是所谓的“朋友”，这都不是关于赢。这不是，就像你永远不会赢。你永远不可能跟这种类型的人赢得胜利。这是关于收回你自己的情感能量，保护你自己的能量，并设定更坚定的界限。你知道的，如果恨意出现在网络上，特别是针对喷子，他们根本不在乎输赢。
They do not care about presenting a solid argument. They do not care about scoring points. The only thing they are looking for is it a reaction. We know that from all of these psychology studies, right? So actually, they want you to engage with them. That's why they're being so inflammatory. The best thing you can do is to just not. the best thing you can do is to just be like cool i see your comment blocked and if everyone did that
他们不在乎提出一个扎实的论点。他们不在乎得分。他们唯一寻找的东西是：一个反应。我们从所有这些心理学研究中都知道这一点，对吧？所以实际上，他们希望你与他们互动。这就是为什么他们如此具有煽动性。你能做的最好的事情就是：不予理睬。你能做的最好的事情就是表现得酷一点：我看到你的评论了，已拉黑。如果每个人都这么做……
it would be like suffocating the hate in them because they wouldn't get the rise out of people that creates like the satisfaction loop for them and that keeps them engaging in this and doing this by refusing to participate you take away their power and gosh do i know how hard it is but something that i choose to do instead because i understand the need to react to someone being hateful or spiteful online is where I see negativity, I leave positivity. If I see like a girl and like dancing in every single comment is like a hate comment, I'm leaving a positive one. And that's how I'm going to choose to engage.
……这就好比是在窒息他们心中的恨意，因为他们无法从人们身上得到能为他们创造满足感循环并让他们继续参与和这样做的情绪反馈。通过拒绝参与，你剥夺了他们的权力。天哪，我知道这有多难，但我选择这样做是因为我理解在线上对充满恨意或恶意的人做出反应的冲动：每当我看到负面情绪时，我就留下正能量。如果我看到某个女孩在跳舞，而每一条评论都是充满恨意的评论，我会留下一个积极的评论。这就是我选择互动的方式。
I'm not going to start replying to people and trying to fight back. I know it's not going to work. I'm just going to match their energy with something like egregiously positive. Same with sometimes when I get troll comments on my own posts. I love to call trolls like honey and sweet cakes and baby cakes and like sweet honeybee or like lovely boy or I love to like give them pet names and like be so like sickly sweet dripping with kindness towards them that like they know they cannot get a rise out of me. I and it works.
我不会开始回复别人并试图反击。我知道这不会起作用。我只会用某种极其正面的东西来匹配他们的能量。有时候我在自己的帖子上收到喷子的评论也是如此。我喜欢叫喷子“亲爱的”、“小甜心”、“心肝宝贝”或者“甜蜜的小蜜蜂”或是“可爱的小男孩”，我喜欢给他们起昵称，表现得极其甜腻、充满善意，以至于他们知道自己无法从我这里激起任何波澜。而且这确实管用。
It does work. In person as well you obviously can't block someone. You can't be like I want to mute this conversation. Goodbye. But you can create an emotional distance. between you and what they're saying by simply just responding in like the most bland way possible. Just being like, that's an interesting perspective. Or I'm sorry you feel that way.
确实管用。在现实生活中，你显然不能拉黑某人。你不能说：我想将这段对话静音。再见。但你可以通过以最平淡的方式回应，在你自己和他们所说的话之间创造情感距离。只要说：这是一个有趣的视角。或者，很遗憾你会有这种感觉。
Like they're a child. Treat them like they're a child. They will lose interest. And they keep saying stuff just being like, I'm really sorry you feel that way. I'm really sorry you feel that way. And you'll slowly say that like they're the ones who, start to realize the ridiculousness of what they're saying and that they're the ones who are pushing a conversation that you obviously don't want to have and it's like they look ridiculous.
就像对待小孩子一样。把他们当作小孩子对待。他们会失去兴趣。如果他们继续说些什么，就只是说：我很遗憾你会有这种感觉。我很遗憾你会有这种感觉。然后你会慢慢地说，就像是他们自己开始意识到他们所说的话有多么荒谬，而且是他们在强行推进一场你明显不想进行的对话，看起来他们真的很荒谬。
Your reaction is so powerful when it is neutral because you're refusing to participate in the emotional side of this game. And so in doing so, you are protecting your own peace. Also, sometimes you just need to take a deep breath and you just need to again remind yourself this has nothing to do with me. anybody here could be the target of this they're just looking for someone to pile their shit onto they're just looking for someone to be like to to get the pleasure that they want out of this hateful feeling it doesn't have to be you you don't have to give them the space you don't have to give them the time the worst thing that can happen in this situation is that you
当你的反应是中立的时候，它是如此强大，因为你拒绝参与这场游戏的情感部分。通过这样做，你正在保护你自己的平静。另外，有时你只需要深呼吸，再次提醒自己这与我无关。这里任何人都可以成为目标，他们只是在寻找一个可以将自己的垃圾倾倒上去的人。他们只是在寻找某人来获取他们从这种充满恨意的感觉中想要的快乐。那个人不必是你，你不必给他们空间，你不必给他们时间。在这种情况下可能发生的最糟糕的事情是……
fall to their level. And I've, I've done this. I've seen it happen so many times. But it's like the moment you get in the mud and start rolling around with them, you are just one of these people. And again, that's a conscious decision you can choose not to make by processing your own dislike for other people or your own insecurity or your own grievances in a healthy way. By knowing that There's no such thing as a wrong emotion, but there is a better reaction, and you're going to choose to take the better path. That's a long freaking journey. And again, I think especially right now, it's the harder choice.
……你降到了他们的水平。我曾经这样做过。我看到这种情况发生过太多次了。但这就像是你一旦跳进泥潭里和他们一起打滚，你也就是这些人中的一员了。再说一次，这是一个你可以选择不去做有意识的决定，通过用健康的方式处理你对别人的厌恶、你自己的不安全感或你自己的委屈。通过明白没有所谓的错误情绪，但有更好的反应，而你将选择走更好的路。这是一个漫长的旅程。再说一次，我认为尤其是在现在，这是更艰难的选择。
It is the much harder choice to go high. It will always be more rewarding, and it will always be more importantly, less emotionally exhausting. So with that in mind, I'm going to wrap up the episode. I hope that you learn a little bit more about the psychology behind being a hater, behind why we love to hate, behind, you know, gossiping in cancel culture, and why we secretly can't wait for a celebrity's downfall. I feel like I had a bit of mixed message throughout this episode,
保持高姿态要艰难得多。它永远会更有回报，更重要的是，它在情感上会不那么令人筋疲力尽。带着这一点，我要结束这一集了。希望你们能多了解一点“黑粉”背后的心理学，了解我们为什么喜欢去恨，了解八卦和取消文化背后的原因，以及为什么我们私下里迫不及待地想看到某个名人的垮台。我觉得我在这一集里传达了一些混杂的信息……
but what I really want to say is this is like a completely normal and biological, psychological part of our behavior. But the more we learn about it, the more I think that we can make it more civilized and just appreciate it on like a more nuanced level rather than just being like monkeys pushing a hateful button and being like yes this makes me feel good this makes me feel good like i'm just going to tear other people down you don't have to do that there are other choices and there are other ways to approach hate especially in modern day society where it seems that like everyone is everyone just wants public outrage everyone just wants to be
但我想真正表达的是，这就像是我们行为中一个极其正常且符合生物学和心理学的组成部分。但我们对它了解得越多，我就越觉得我们可以让它变得更文明，并以一种更微妙的水平去欣赏它，而不是像猴子一样按下充满仇恨的按钮，觉得“太棒了，这让我感觉很好，这让我感觉很好，我就是要去贬低别人”。你其实没必要这么做，还有其他的选择，也有其他的方式来应对仇恨，尤其是在现代社会中，似乎每个人都渴望引发公众的愤怒，每个人都只想成为
the meanest, cruelest person in the comment section so they get the most engagement, like, nah, we don't have to do that. That's, we don't actually have to be a part of that. We can handle that in a better way. So I hope that is what you have learned or taken away from this episode. If you have made it this far, I've been really enjoying song recommendations recently. Leave your most like angry song, like the song you get, you let all your rage and your hate and your spy out to in the comments below.
评论区里最尖酸刻薄、最残忍的人，以此来获得最高的互动量。就像是，得了吧，我们没必要那样做。实际上，我们不必参与其中。我们可以用更好的方式来处理它。所以，我希望这就是你从本期节目中学到或收获的东西。如果你听到了这里，我最近真的很喜欢向大家推荐歌曲。请在下方的评论区留下你最喜欢的一首“愤怒之歌”，也就是那种能让你把所有的愤怒、仇恨和积怨都宣泄出来的歌。
You know the song that I'm going to recommend, which is not one that I normally get my anger and spy out to, but which I love as part of this like hate anger cycle is I'm not angry anymore by Paramour. And I love listening to that song when I feel like a lot of rage coming into my body. I'm like, the higher path, the better path. So song recommendation to end the episode.
你知道我要推荐哪首歌吗？这虽然不是我平时用来发泄愤怒和积怨的歌，但我非常喜欢它，觉得它是这种“仇恨-愤怒”循环的一部分，那就是Paramore的《I'm Not Angry Anymore》。当我感觉到体内涌起大量怒火时，我很喜欢听这首歌。我会想：走更高的境界，走更好的路。这就是本期节目结尾的歌曲推荐。
I want to thank our researcher, Colbert for her contributions to this episode. She is amazing. She is incredible. We couldn't do it without her. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to provide an episode suggestion, if you want to contribute to a future episode, if you have further thoughts on online hate and why we love being a hater, I would love to hear from you and I'd love to hear those thoughts. Make sure as well that you are following wherever you are listening on Spotify, Apple Podcast, the IHartRadio app. I don't know. I don't know where you're listening from, but I would love if you stuck around for a little bit longer.
我要感谢我们的研究员Colbert对本期节目的贡献。她太棒了，太不可思议了。如果没有她，我们根本无法完成这一切。请确保在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast。如果你想提供节目建议，如果你想为未来的节目贡献力量，如果你对网络仇恨以及为什么我们喜欢当一个“喷子”有进一步的看法，我很乐意听到你的声音，也很想听听这些想法。另外，请确保在你的听歌平台上关注我们，无论是Spotify、Apple Podcast还是iHeartRadio应用。我不知道，我不知道你是在哪里收听的，但我希望你能多留一会儿。
So hit follow, make sure to give us a five-star review. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. Handle that hate with care. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
所以，点击关注，一定要给我们一个五星好评。直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。小心处理那些仇恨。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that
我剖析了精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。也就是iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方上的TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重大时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite
我是Sam J。我是Alex English。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，弄清楚我们是如何在那个年代活过来的。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。我是说，那真的是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，由你们最喜欢的
therapist and host, Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
治疗师兼主持人Kier Games为您主持。这个空间主要探讨黑人群体的男性经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着西装，就像穿着盔甲一样？它向世界释放的信号是：你是不容好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控生下了双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，这份特定的检测你做过两次，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我伪造了一次检测。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。Greg Gillespie和Michael Mancini。我当时惊呆了。我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an I-Heart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客，保证由真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。